help me understand like y'all two
obviously we see a lot of dysfunction
how much of the dysfunction is for
entertainment purposes and how much of
it is like because you guys are pretty
dysfunctional
in terms of what we see will the
dysfunction just becomes from
like we do business together and we
together so it's like
y'all don't know half the time which one
is going on right and we don't know half
the time which one is going on so it's
like
that's the destruction no it's the fact
that it works yeah yeah no we really
don't give a [__] about what y'all think
but right like when we going through our
things and we don't get what's going on
you know so to her it might seem like
I'm tripping off her taking a picture or
whatnot right right but to me it's more
like I'm on some benefit like it's not a
it's it's not if it's not like a
beneficial look I I personally don't
agree with it well technically you're
are you her manager yeah yeah like I
signed up so she's like so she's saying
to you as an artist yeah she's your lady
exactly she's your your baby mom you're
soon to be more complicated so it's like
when people like say like oh she's
complicated and complicated
he was like that's a good thing because
she signed to you yeah true yeah right
you think I I put bring somebody to
Captain and be like um I want her to get
to where I'm at like so let me figure so
so this is the thing though right
because if we think about her as an
artist because she has music and she
assigned to you wouldn't because I saw
you did get a little you got kind of mad
about her taking a picture with Rick
Ross
and communicating with little baby on
some big bro [__] as an artist wouldn't
it be so annoying well wouldn't it be
smart for her to network with Rick Ross
and little baby for her career hell no
why not because they're not gonna what
he said
it's not it's not gonna be real
networking you know what I'm saying it's
gonna be like because if I'm managing an
artist and they can
chop it up with Rick Ross or chop it up
a little baby who's one of the hottest
artists in the world I would encourage
that
not when they're trying to [__] that's
what he's different so do you think
they're trying to [__]
he says it I just be like I don't know
she she knows she she liked to play
around
so like little baby chopping it up with
you calling you big bro his big bro but
you didn't like obviously I saw the
tweets no that was the that was the
throw-off that's not what he was telling
her while he was in front of her type
[__] you know so when he was in front of
you was it like more like what's good
or was it like hey I see what you're
doing you're killing it that's what he
was like that's what I figured right
yeah but she's lying she didn't tell you
he was like oh you sexy uh I want you
around oh you got potential come to the
studio
what's your number let's look like
cousins
it wasn't that trust me babe why are you
taking everything so loud it should live
you try to water her down
and okay it's cool if she networking
there you go if she never gonna it's by
all means it's cool right but once
there's money being talked about and
business that's being exchanged now it's
unprofessional so if a little baby just
invites her to the studio
and you're not there you're you're not
okay with that
oh no I'm okay with that okay I'm okay
with that how about that song yeah but
it better be it better be something
transpiring it better not be like what
if they're just listening to beats and
they're chopping it up about like her
career whatever whatever and like a song
well then I would have to be there
anything what has to do with her career
I have to be there to speak at her best
you know
do you feel like your relationship your
personal relationship could Cloud your
managerial relationship
I don't know because it's almost to the
point where it's like
if I wasn't a rapper that would make
sense right but I am which means all I
gotta do is take care of where I go yeah
rolling out just take it all right do
yourself uh show okay do your set so
it's kind of like it doesn't like if I
wasn't a rapper then it'll be like I'm
getting in the way
because
I have nothing to offer her from the
artist side of things right I'm blocking
her from
somebody else putting her on they said
and some you know what I'm saying so no
I don't think it'll fix you also gotta
understand too like she is on fire right
now so if you're Rick Ross and you see
Christian rock at the Super Bowl you're
gonna be like oh [__] let's get a flick
no you're not why not do you think Rick
Ross does that no I actually do think
that because Rick Ross is a pretty like
like mellow dude I feel like he was
probably high as [__] at the Super Bowl
he was like oh [__] you're the girl on
the internet wow being nice that's crazy
yeah I think Rick Ross walk up to
[__] that's famous and say can I get
a picture of you you're high right now
you think that's what Rick Ross does
what do you think it was a whole list of
people what do you think happened what
do you think happened blue
all I can speak on is what what I think
that they're thinking they never seen
her in person and obviously when you see
a person she's bad as hell so it's like
oh [__] it's her right and it's like
that's cool but you also like no you
can't just don't be unprofessional buddy
don't go up to her and be like yo I
think we can do business and let's let's
do this and let's do that let's do that
like that's like me walking up to to
what a little baby artist for today and
I'm like yo bro I think you dope artist
you got potential look I got this much
money for you let's let's figure out how
we can keep you around and make you big
little baby's gonna be like bro what the
[__] are you doing this is my artist
like what why would you you want to do a
song or something great tell them to
contact send a song make it professional
how about this what if her networking
with a little baby equals eventually her
getting a feature from little baby which
would be big for her career no
because that's not his character how
many females do you know little baby to
do music with
I don't know okay how many famous
rappers do you think Lil Baby has had
sex with
I don't know I don't want to speculate
on another man do you think I don't know
another man's dick you know what I'm
saying [__] his dick we're talking about
I just asked you how many females have
you seen him to do music with
I can't think of many okay why do you
think that is I don't know that's
probably not his thing right
that's fair is she the hottest musical
artist out right now as a female no so
does that make sense to you
look you want to know what's crazy about
the whole situation she came up with
this rule okay what's that
I can't work with any female artists
did you come up with this rule
after the fact that something that
happened
it's not the best rule it's a terrible
Rule
now
it works
the same thing oh so what you even
talking to them for if you came up with
this weird-ass rule
gotta get rid of that rule man
tell her you're like I got paid 40 000
from a female to do a song she talking
about give it back because he was
because I said
he didn't take me to the video shoot
none of that he was being weird so he's
been weird with the feature it made me
like what that's that's what what
happened we was beefing you didn't
invite me nowhere when you was doing it
right and then he was making like you
doing something way more important than
hanging out with me like it was weird
what does that have to do with it yeah
it's like certain things he do it get
out of my skin shut the [__] up
what I'd like to say it's really good to
see both of y'all without a bottle of
Hennessy around that's great
do you feel like Christian like you guys
were like becoming a little dependent on
the bottle for a while you don't feel
like everywhere I would see y'all
there'd be a [__] no I just like the
bottom you just like Hennessy yeah a
little too much no I'm not dealing with
him no she's like I need it [__]